what do you think is the biggest
misconception about la in general i
think like
living here for five or six years now
i think it's like
from my perspective it's like people
come out here but they don't really ever
come to la they go to like the valley or
they go to hollywood or they go to bed
and they think that's l.a exactly really
the closest part of la they've been to
is when they landed exactly exactly i
think the biggest misconception is that
everybody in la is fake it's like nah
man you stay north of the 10 freeway
like you know you
are on
no disrespect on fairfax all day on
melrose all day and you know it's kind
of like oh go where the culture is you
know go go where you can get some good
food at go you know
room right on lamert park you know where
where where where you get a sense of
like real community you know so
i feel i i personally feel like that's
the biggest misconception of la and a
lot of times
honestly
it'd be
like people that will come here and
adapt to a mentality that they feel like
they have to have to live in l.a
and a lot of people you know for the
most part you know they they meet people
like that and they feel like everybody
in l.a is like that and that's not well
and most of the time because like
there's been a few people that have gone
la viral for talking [ __ ] about l.a
right
r b singers we won't get into the who's
in the weeds of it
but it's like people who aren't even
from here exactly and it's like
obviously you're probably mostly
interacting with people who aren't from
here as well
and or are very much like involved in
the entertainment industry and
unfortunately exactly in the
entertainment industry it just is what
it is most people are full of [ __ ]
everywhere and no matter what you're a
part of yeah but like i do feel like
particularly like i understand how
someone could be scorned by like their
experience in the music industry but
like
just because someone lives here like you
know they're right it's not the same
thing correct and it's like if you're
not from here shut the [ __ ] up that's it
like you're you're here you're here you
know you're taking the good right you
love the like there's a reason why
you're here right exactly because you
kind of have to be here for your career
correct so if you could get all that
positive out of los angeles
but didn't want to go on twitter and
[ __ ] on like
[ __ ] homeless people or the whole you
know all these little things it's like
all right right at least beautiful
though man like there's so many
different like nuances and like
la is such a dynamic city it's like
really whatever you're looking for you
get here yeah exactly and really if you
just if you want to drive within like
three hours of la it's like really
limitless it's like you could go to the
[ __ ] desert and trip on shrooms at
joshua tree
you can go to irvine and exactly go to
that
it's it's just so many different layers
to the city you know like how you said
you want to go to
joshua tree palm springs coachella it's
not too far from that it's like its own
little country low-key southern
california it's wild correct